hey this is presh talwalkar
start with semi-circle a b and flip it
upside down so that semi-circle c d is
tangent to semi-circle a b
the two semi-circles are also positioned
such that the line through a b
is tangent to the semicircle cd and the
line through cd is exactly tangent to
the semi-circle a b
if each semi-circle has a diameter equal
to two
what is the length of a d equal to
write your answer in the form of the
square root of x plus the square root of
y
where x and y
are whole numbers greater than or equal
to 1 and x is less than y
a version of this problem was asked in a
mathematical olympiad qualifying test in
the philippines
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
let's review the following geometric
concept if two circles are tangent their
centers and the tangent point are
collinear
suppose we have circles a and b that are
tangent
let t be the tangent point
draw the line through t
by the given information a t is
perpendicular to the tangent line and bt
is also perpendicular to the tangent
line therefore
atb is a straight line segment
this is true for both externally and
internally tangent circles
so now let's solve the problem
let's construct the center of each
semicircle and the tangent point
by the principle we just showed these
three points will be on a straight line
segment
now construct the following tangent
point of semi-circle a b to the line
going through c d
let's drop this perpendicular which is
also a radius of the semi-circle a b
now each semi-circle has a diameter
that's equal to two which is equal to
one plus one
so each semi-circle has a radius that's
equal to one
so let's focus on this right triangle
the shorter leg will be equal to one so
the hypotenuse will be equal to one plus
one
so the hypotenuse will be equal to two
we thus have a thirty sixty ninety
special right triangle
so we know that the longer leg will be
equal to the square root of three but if
you didn't recall that fact you could
also figure it out using our favorite
right triangle theorem it'll be equal to
the square root of 2 squared minus 1
squared which is equal to the square
root of 3.
so now let's go back to our original
diagram
from the point a construct a
perpendicular to the line going through
cd
this will also have a length that's
equal to one
we also have a length that's equal to
one here because it's equal to a radius
of the semi-circle a b
let's now construct a right triangle
where a d is the hypotenuse
we know that the shorter leg is equal to
one and the longer leg is equal to two
plus the square root of three
so we can figure out the length of a d
it'll be equal to the square root of the
quantity two plus the square root of
three squared plus one squared
we now just need to simplify this
so first we'll expand the binomial
then we'll group like terms
so we're almost there we just need to
write this in terms of the form square
root of x plus the square root of y
to do that we'll square both sides
we'll get rid of the square root on the
left hand side so it's equal to eight
plus four times the square root of three
we then will expand the right side
now since x and y
are positive whole numbers greater than
or equal to 1
we can write the square root of x times
the square root of y is equal to the
square root of x times y
so now let's continue our simplification
we want to make the left-hand side in
the same form as the right-hand side
so let's do a little trick we'll rewrite
4 as equal to 2 times 2.
then 2 is equal to the square root of 4.
from here the square root of 4 times the
square root of 3 is equal to the square
root of 12.
so now both sides of this equation have
the same form so we can equate like
terms so we will equate 8 with x plus y
that gives us one equation
and then we'll equate 2 times the square
root of x y with 2 times the square root
of 12
meaning 12 is equal to x times y
so we have a system of two equations
in the left-hand side we'll solve for y
eight minus x is equal to y
we substitute that into the second
equation so we get 12 is equal to x
multiplied by the quantity eight minus x
we'll then distribute the x term
we now have a quadratic equation x
squared minus eight x plus 12 is equal
to zero
we can factor this rather easily it'll
be factored into the linear terms of x
minus two and x minus six
we thus have two solutions x is equal to
two and x is equal to six
we can solve for y by substituting into
the equation y is equal to eight minus x
this yields y is equal to 6 and y is
equal to 2.
but recall we want x to be less than y
so we'll just take the solution x is
equal to 2 and y is equal to 6.
from here we just go back to our nested
radical and we substitute in the square
root of 8 plus 4 times the square root
of 3 is equal to the square of x plus
the square root of y where x is equal to
2 and y is equal to 6. so this is equal
to the square root of 2 plus the square
root of 6 and that's approximately equal
to 3.86
and that's the answer
what an interesting problem
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you